[Aplausos]
olá bom dia meu nome é juliana e eu
tenho 29 anos é economista de formação
ao tenista por fight
quando eu seu convite por estar aqui na
minha reação foi esta foi o jeito é
juliana estava desmaiada
a gente está no chão sem chance irmão
mais procurados maio e eu acho que vai
haver uma parte do justin o que é quase
não saiu de s.paulo o painel salvar uma
pessoa super formal depois do do boca a
história de john button e depois não
gosta desta desde maio ea seguinte ao
encarar o desafio a contar minha
história e que não havia nada na
história da moda
agora minha não passou mais uma vez seu
nome na costa rica história da morte
dela eu não sei falar do que fazer
acontecer
havia portanto vamos pensar em popular é
esse não sou eu é uma espessa e eu na
china representaram caneca quando eu
brincava com parafuso sol em nada
criada pelo novo joaquim ram
infelizmente até o sertão antes quando
eu sou seu hall e tudo aquilo que está
funcionado com uma pausa para café não
era alto e estranho pra mim tal como
é uma cozinheira uma reforma estranha
pra ela ou não só para sair de graça já
pato também não é pra mim
a desatenção internet e não ser
propriamente um negócio assim nenhum pra
mim era natural o mundo tal não quer
brincar também que essa sou eu o meu
batizado imagine a limpar aquelas
paredes está em plena na piscina ela
pula na piscina do novo quando foi
batizada a minha vida eu gosto porque
não foram servidos na piscina
sou eu não sei que aquela gente na
cabeça é normalmente os empreendedores
na chega a vender coisas não é exposto
avó
os ovos das galinhas da rua e da vizinha
não sei que obviamente não só com esse
ajuste na cabeça desvalorizar não ia ter
essa surpresa bastante que são eu não
mexia vender nada e nunca vai florir da
vizinha nem a roupa vender simplesmente
o chipre em cairo em filmes
depois de algum trabalho da minha mãe
tamanho da influência do meu avô que é
um exemplo o próprio visado do trabalho
a resistência cívica a ministra erenice
trabalhou em programas semelhantes
ministro
lá no meu mundo e aquilo e não desculpa
aí eu acho que é ministra é a
oportunidade ao pular o mundo
o meu e dos outros por aí
a ministra que isto lá também é que ela
garante um sonho grande faz eu tenho que
estudar nunca me filiei ao partido
porque no funk quando terminei o curso
foi trabalhar com uma consultora cuca o
primeiro a conhecer empresas que eu
sabia que queria criar meu próprio
negócio criar meu próprio negócio era
dessa forma a forma que eu te encontrar
todo lugar no mundo e daquelas título
vii-a mais flexível ministra
assim interessa meio na altura tanto a
mãe quanto a nomes e trabalhar com a
consultora
vocês vêem a empregada sociedade via
externa mas foi a guarda faz antigo
buscará a saga de consultora camisa
branca moeda em cava e ia ser consultora
mas algum dia eu pensei na minha vida
empresas de consultoria financeira e nas
empresas é um salário confortável era a
senhora doutora estava sentava no catar
e não sujar mas se trocar o chaves aos
fumos votos pequena dose e criar uma
empresa metalomecânica ea minha mãe
minha câmera uma paga por causa daquele
lugar e chegou a pesar com a efe tentou
fechar um pouco a minha festa cara isso
o que é este e fizesse com sua forma as
suas linhas alunos a dança popular e não
pense nisto abandona tudo o trabalho
certo o que o teu salário faltava
acho que o emprego a gente terminar por
cima da hora já popular e os restantes
ruas por isso e agora toda vez que este
tipo de crime o empresário falou também
que calçar umas roupas brinquedos
esta reação não foi só da minha mãe mas
sim várias pessoas enviavam e pesar mais
uma vez o que faça costa mendonça está
maluca
ela está numa luta fica lá eu tô novo
não vai conseguir
ela não vai ser algo está morto ela não
vai conseguir andar na frente com um
negócio que já não tem parte da tarde
mas é e pensar e pensa e reinventar a
minha forma de estar na vida
se o grêmio lar em quando aparecem
história quando era menina
depois empresária quase consegue pensar
com carinho o que tinha que fazer para
mudar o meu mundo novo que tenha será
que ela está em uma consultora já foi eu
não bateria tentar comenda apesar da
morte anunciada pela minha mãe falou do
meu da minha mão e se calhar nunca
dinheiro da minha aventura não dispense
a pescar
eu tenho na favela eu tenho a
anos era jovem não
na pior das hipóteses eu iria falhar
iria falhar de quintal como era nosso
falhar eu iria aprender como eu iria
aprender confiança mas eu não ia provar
ser um raça memória também criou fez
aquilo que eu sou
portanto eu tinha entra a dúvida não
tentar não perdoar nunca ter tentado a
tentar e tentar o que eu fiz é
reinventar o negócio que é novo é uma
metalomecânica que era totalmente
direcionada para empresas de construção
civil nacional e internacional a empresa
está presente atualmente é uma empresa
que faz manutenção para essa venda de
caminhões
estudei muito o meu problema é
profissionalizar o site onde um ser
totalmente tradicional
eu cheguei por exemplo as pessoas que
comandavam não ligava de juliana oito
mandatos um orçamento e no lindo e se as
bandagens eu o pai está uma inovação
dentro receber todos os setores do
werder cento sobre de ferro um álbum de
mraz banda pulso salto naide temos raça
e fazemos carros pelas drogas desde os
jogos de volta os pequenos na escolha
das suas nestes setores tão tradicional
e então estava se não trabalhar da mesma
forma que eu aprendi a trabalhar
então você é profissionalizar o setor
eu mesmo tempo fiz um bocadinho lavagem
cerebral nos funcionários e as pessoas
trabalhavam na fazenda são os galletti
em cannes só vai legal vamos também sabe
cortar a mão de obra não qualificada
fiz algumas lajes liberado porque estava
vendo a zorra e com trabalho
o conselho já havia levado o input valor
do jantar de natal a jogar bola fazer um
churrasco
temos um funcionário do mês e sempre
temos funcionários da empresa só tem uma
premissa tanto e passaram a ser tratados
de forma diferente não tenha se trata de
quem não tem empresa ao mesmo tempo meu
cunha sabe aquilo que você sabe que eu
sei o que é preciso tentar agora eu
tenho que saber qual é o futuro um setor
do leite é o primeiro a oferecer ajuda
os mais doentes assunção mas não agora
mais marcas mas é forte
independentemente do meu trabalho ser
sujo com olga benário
no tórax um pouco menos ou contratei e
consegue até ando eu estava com vontade
com uma história muito relacionado com
sexo está nova feminina website em
novembro do ano passado eo primeiro web
que abriram e sabe porque minha empresa
há pouco mais de um ano vindo do santo
considerava em uma data não era
tecnológica
não acho que tenha aumentado
eu não tenho de trabalhar e portanto não
vou sair por tempo e pensar só depois
com souza e agora só me consolar noite
pode terça quarta e quinta é para as
palestras e no domingo e um sábado só
falavam coisas sabe que afinal ter um
ritmo que estará em lisboa no domingo à
tarde
olha olha também vai até o dia 30 só eu
não interfiro na segunda dia quando não
jogo não agora que eu quero nem não
então não adianta tentar arranjar uma
mulher telefona para baixo pelas 90 onde
eu vou tentar muito triste ver naquela
função da faixa de areia solta a idéia
de um jornalista que a princesa assim e
olha que ele estava a precisar de uma
câmera uma eu vou é sair pega na tela
vai jua's palestras e conhecer gente
carrega uma câmera como a creche normal
então deixe na geladeira nem
a média diária eo próximo entretanto já
no espeto pessoal com várias força e
toda a gente dizia que não ia conseguir
dentro da lei
a dança nóis vai falar com o vereador da
câmara do porto
eu sou assim cada chapa e não falar
conta foi invadida desde senhora idosa é
esse tipo uma linha e assistência e até
falta de vergonha está a contactar o
facebook mas é que eu estava me ajuda
não é nem sabia exatamente o que queria
que eu posso fazer
o prêmio tem um deles na europa creia
média deve contar meus sonhos mas os
filhos da senhora olha se eu a manhã
estiveram smt passa no vosso na nossa
terrinha costumam inventar muito mais é
muito bem vinda
ela é daquelas honda accord sair pra
começar na terça dia 19 quando eu
acordei na terça tem até uns com quem é
esse
bom ele tem das duas e meia da manhã
para ir ao ar somente um sábado naquela
terça feira
a manhã acordou e aos gritos e se não
acredita que o setor sabe que foi mal e
sendo assim não contar que tal
jornalista tem até agora era pra mim
especificamente da manhã o tempo de
existência
nós vamos fazer a nossa vida os nossos
negócios e em tudo o que eu constato na
frente
o verde é s
a empresa só que o google essa vontade
não é sangue cowboy deixou por não
suportar
foi assim que a nova mamãe era ainda hã
hã hãe aqueles que querem explicar a fé
ainda por cima o lixo não sei que é a
genética
o bom é que valem só a noite toda olha
acho que você sabe qual é sua
eu não tenho um lado não tem lá eu não
tenho perfil para caminhos luiz não
desmatar ou já jô ou faço agora a
transferência com prazer ao ler o que eu
fiz uma empresa metalomecânica que foi
cansaço já estava foi profissionalizado
no nono lugar em casa é eu não faço essa
pergunta se ela não quiser usar a
transformar no setor profissional no
carro senão inovação desse tipo malpensa
sr tem hoje é igual e não seremos nós é
inovar sem ser apenas com a tecnologia
não sendo que alguns outro contra ataque
onde até fama está em um plano segue
lógica sim um quando o mapa minha
empresa mas para já com um único venda
não estava nos planos se eu conquistar
em 100 a 78 sexy sem mandar obra
qualificada sem um um produto altamente
tecnológico que a todos deve fazer isso
e foram alunos dizer porque eu vim aqui
hoje eu estava cansado será deixar os
modos de pensamento o certo pelo incerto
efetivamente tenham solar e confortável
acima da média em teolândia
mas se ele passar com esse é mais um que
há um certo senão lutar para que eles
que contará a história de agosto
efetivamente nós temos amor por aquilo
que fazemos na nossa atividade para nós
somos persistentes
o inferno é rua e nós vamos fazer
acontecer independentemente do que é
certo é que a mulher tem muito esta que
está na regra não está não tava na cara
e talento como engenheiros como internet
não tive o carinho eu sou mais flashes
vocês podem ter a nossa frente é
importante sim só deve tomar não vamos
com muita com muita cumplicidade com
muito orgulho e com muita luta
a tecnológica vai se motiva o que é uma
data senão empresas eram usuários de
internet do google china e da internet
mas neste momento e tal como o vereador
falou pessoas falaram construído a
pensar reinventar as nossas empresas e
não é só na tecnologia até tecnológica
estão a fazer é criar um novo mercado é
constituído por pensar que eu tenho nada
contra as outras mas as nossas também é
altamente motivados isto é espectacular
porque não tem mão de obra qualificada
ainda nem não trabalhar com históricos
complicada em cima de vida nova
oportunidade
hoje que não tem carta de condução a
escolha de talentos fica só com isso já
não consegue ser comerciais qualquer
coisa que eu já entrei por isso é uma
obra qualificada é normal e rondó
altamente motivadas é bahia ea minha
manobra é algo muito motivada
estamos com pessoas têm um valor extremo
porque eu sei que a minha equipa num
cenário equipa e sem o amor tem por ela
quando ingressa não sou ninguém e acho
que temos que pensar e pensar já dentro
e eu estava pra ver essa falência no
início da tarde já não só
mas é que eu conhecer é que não seja só
a gente trabalha muito trabalho pra mim
muito aula vamos sujar muitos parafusos
para substituir muita chata mundo os
fundos da minha juiz muitas drogas pra
mim e para aquelas que estão com isso
porque só assim é que eu vou conseguir
mudar o meu mundo ir até o fundo vai
máquinas por exemplo um grande obrigada
em espécie
[Aplausos]